playing Elton has been kind of a
revelation for me obviously with him
doing such a style icon and a pioneer of
a certain aesthetic that's all his own
[Music]
[Applause]
Elton has been a hero of music and of
style
I mean Elton John in his own right has
been a style icon to millions Froman
Rocket Man was a kind of great excuse
for me to to read up on Elton John Ben
Elton's had so many iconic different
looks and still continues to I mean that
I love some of these things some of the
things we've got in the film of Tyron
with these huge feather wings or or that
kind of mad chicken outfit he did the
donald duck thing didn't he that one I
remember it stands out very specifically
I remember in like the kind of research
in the film I played Bernie Taupin who's
the the songwriter and a longtime
collaborate with Alton John and I think
it kind of upset Bernie a bit that they
can about landish clothes that he would
wear because he would say we've written
these beautiful songs that kind of stand
alone as these kind of great pieces of
work you don't need to sing your song in
a Donald Duck costume it's kind of
amazing that he was brave enough to do
that and and also that his performances
were also always bigger than these crazy
outfits which is seeing something my
favorite outfit in the movie my favorite
costume is not one that was very
comfortable to wear but that seems to
sort of characterize Elton's taste in
their in clothing it's an orange
Elvis shape it's got that kind of saggy
cuff and the big collar an ear frame
helmet with these huge horns two massive
orange wings and seven-inch heels you
know he's a larger-than-life human being
and I get it you know I think he always
thought of himself as they kind of stuck
behind this piano there's nothing for
people today gonna really get a show out
of it he he's certainly a showman he
wanted to give them their
[Music]
my style icon is a fictitious character
is called Dickie Greenleaf and it is
Jude Law's character from the talented
mr. Ripley
Vicki Greenlee I would say also that
it's probably the most stylish ensemble
in a film possibly ever met its movie
stars of the height of their moment
everyone just looks beautiful in the
film the film shots stunningly everyone
just looks like a model that beautiful
elegant rich it's yeah it Dickie
Greenleaf for me is big icon of mine do
I have personal style yours I mean I'm
someone who kind of has moments of
feeling quite stylish but I'm also
someone who's quite simple really I'm
you know I'm a country boy for me you
can't be a sort of a skinny jean pair of
Converse and a white team like Marlon
Brando did his heyday and then a nice
simple bomber or a leather or something
and I don't get much more outlandish
than that really
[Music]
generally I look quite well-dressed when
someone else is dressed
[Music]